>> Greg: AFTER FIERCE BACKLASH
DEMOCRATS ARE SCALING DOWN PLANS
TO SNOOP IN YOUR BANK ACCOUNT.
INSTEAD OF SPYING ON ACCOUNTS
WITH THEIR 600, THE NEW PLAN IS
$10,000.
HOWEVER, MILLIONS OF AMERICANS
ARE STILL FACING A MAJOR
INVASION OF PRIVACY FROM UNCLE
SAM.
THE WHITE HOUSE IS TRYING TO
SPIN THE PROPOSAL AS WAY TO GO
AFTER BILLIONAIRES AND NOT THE
AVERAGE TAXPAYER.
>> ANYWHERE THEY MAY BE GETTING
W-2, THAT IS NOT WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HERE, THEY ARE
REPORTING THEIR INCOME.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT PEOPLE WHO
ARE HIGH NET WORTH INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE NOT PAYING TAXESS THEY
OWE.
SOMETHING WE THINK EVERYBODY
BELIEVES SHOULD HAPPEN AND CAN
HELP PAY FOR RANGE OF IMPORTANT
INVESTMENTS TO MAKE US MORE
COMPETITOR.
>> Greg: KATIE, FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT, FRAUD, THEY WANT TO
LOOK AT YOUR ACCOUNT, I WANT TO
LOOK AT YOURS.
>> Katie: THIS POLICY PROVES
THAT THIS NARRATIVE THEY HAVE
BEEN TRYING TO SELL FOR TWO
WEEKS ABOUT THE BILL COSTING
ZERO DOLLARS IS COMPLETE
GARBAGE.
JEN PSAKI IS SAYING, WE HAVE TO
DO THIS, WE'RE RAISING THE
THRESHOLD TO $10,000, WE WILL GO
AFTER BILLIONAIRES WHO ARE NOT
PAYING TAXES, IT IS ABOUT PAYING
FOR THIS BILL AND GOVERNMENT
POWER AND GIVING DEMOCRATS MORE
OF IT.
THE I.R.S. NEEDS MORE POWER.
THEY WANT BANKS TO HIRE MORE
PEOPLE, MORE I.R.S. AGENTS.
GIVE THEM MORE FUNDING, IT IS
DIFFICULT TO SCALE IT BACK.
IT IS ABOUT MAKING SURE GIG
WORKERS ARE TAKEN OUT OF THE
ECONOMY.
IF YOU HAVE SOMEONE WHO IS
CONTRACTOR, DOESN'T GET NORMAL
W-2 FORM, WHO WORKS FOR
THEMSELVES, BUSINESS NOT A
CORPORATION, THIS IS SOMETHING
THEY WILL BE LOOKING AT CLOSELY
WITH THE I.R.S. AND DEMOCRATS
MADE IT CLEAR, THEY WANT
EVERYONE TO BE EMPLOYEE SO THEY
CAN BE UNIONIZED.
THEY ARE LYING ABOUT THE ZERO
DOLLAR THING, THIS PROVES IT,
$10,000 THRESHOLD IS TOO LOW, IF
THEY ARE GOING AFTER
BILLIONAIRES.
>> Greg: HAROLD, YOU WANT YOUR
BANK WORKING WITH THE FEDS ON
THIS?
>> Harold: NO, THE NUMBER IS TOO
LOW, $10,000 IS TOO LOW TO SNOOP
IN EVERYONE'S ACCOUNT.
HOW DO YOU MAKE THE TAX CODE
FAIRER?
FIRST ISSUE WAS IMMIGRATION.
IMMIGRATION IS TAXES, WE'VE NOT
HAD COMPREHENSIVE REFORM SINCE
1996, RONALD REAGAN WAS
PRESIDENT.
WE NEED TO HAVE ONE.
THIS EFFORT HERE, IMMATURE,
BRING IN RICH PEOPLE WHO HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO GET AWAY WITHOUT
PAYING THEIR TAXES, WHAT SHOULD
WE DO NOT TO ALLOW THE
ULTRA-RICH TO AVOID TAXES.
>> Greg: TRAITORS, HAROLD.
>> Harold: I THINK WE CAN ALL
AGREE, PEOPLE WHO LIVE THEIR
LIVES IN SHIELDED INCOME SHOULD
PAY TAXES, I THINK THAT IS THE
POINT.
YOUR POINT, KATIE, $600,
$10,000, YOU WILL HIRE PEOPLE
THAT DO NOT GET THE CRUX OF
THIS.
I AM NOT SURE DEMOCRATS WANT
EVERYBODY UNIONIZED.
I DON'T THINK THIS IS THE WAY TO
DO IT.
$10,000 WILL NOT SOLVE THIS
PROBLEM.
>> Greg: GOOD THING YOU KEEP
YOUR MONEY OFFSHORE.
WAS I SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT?
SORRY.
>> Dana: I LEARNED FROM THE
BEST, GUTFELD TOLD ME THAT YEARS
AGO.
THE THING, THEY GOT CAUGHT.
DEMOCRATS THOUGHT THEY COULD
SPLIP THIS BY YOU.
REMEMBER WHEN OBAMACARE PASSED
AND WAIT, WHAT?
IT BECAME SUPER UNPOPULAR AND
MOUNTED AND TOXICITY,
CONGRESSMAN BANKES FROM INDIANA,
RUNS A COMMITTEE, HE HAS HIS
TEAM GO THROUGH AND FIND THIS.
DEMOCRATS PUTTING THIS IN THERE,
LIKE THE WORST BOND VILLAIN, I
KNOW, WE ARE SO POPULAR, WE
SHOULD GIVE MORE MONEY TO THE
MOST UNPOPULAR AND TO THE
FEDERAL GOVERNMENT AND I.R.S.
IT BACKFIRED ON THEM.
THE OTHER THING TO KATIE'S
POINT, IF THE BILL DOESN'T COST
ANYTHING, COSTS ZERO, YOU
WOULDN'T NEED THIS.
>> Greg: INVESTIGATE BORDER
PATROL, GIVE I.R.S. AGENTS A
RAISE.
>> Jesse: $10,000 IF YOU BUY A
CAR, DOWN PAYMENT ON A HOUSE.
YOU ARE SCOOPING UP A LOT OF
PEOPLE.
I THINK, PERMISSION TO BASH THE
MEDIA.
>> PERMISSION GRANTED.
>> Greg: HOW DID THIS HAPPEN?
MEDIA OBSESSED WITH AUTHOR
TEARIANISM AS THOUGH IT COMES
FROM THE RIGHT.
THEY ARE NOT PART OF THE RIGHT,
HATE REPUBLICANS.
THEY ENVISION IT IS SOMEBODY,
TRUMP, BEFORE TRUMP IT WAS BUSH,
BEFORE BUSH, IT WAS REAGAN.
CREATE DYSTOPIA, BUT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT IT, THEY MISSED IMPULSE
OF THE LEFT.
IT IS THERE, WHETHER COMMUNIST
CHINA, HO CHI MINH.
I CAN'T IMAGINE TRUMP WANTING TO
SNOOP THROUGH BANK ACCOUNTS.
IF YOU LOOK AT THIS STUFF AND
STEP BACK AND LOOK AT SPEECH
CODE, VACCINE MANDATES, PARENTS
PROTECTING THEIR CHILDREN, WE
ARE GOING TOWARD UTAUPIA.
IT IS ALL ACADEMICS, IT IS ALL
POLITICIANS, PROGRESSIVES,
WOKESTERS, ALL THERE.
>> Jesse: FOX HAS TO PAY ME IN
BITCOIN, THAT IS NOT EVEN A
NEGOTIATION, PAY IN BITCOIN,
RIGHT? WE WILL GET PAID IN
BITCOIN.
UP NEXT, MORE FOREIGN POLICY